In einer Gondel die Kanäle hinabgleiten -
selbst für den erfahrenen Gondoliere
Maurizio Carlotto
immer noch ein romantisches Erlebnis.
Natürlich sind Frauen die beste Kundschaft,
obwohl ich das nicht sagen sollte.
Ganz gleich welcher Nationalität.
Er ist einer von Venedigs
rund 600 Gondolieri.
Normalerweise macht Carlotto
drei Touren am Tag,
aber seit Beginn der Pandemie
ist er praktisch arbeitslos.
Seit Oktober habe ich
eine einzige Fahrt gemacht.
Die Stadt erwacht gerade
aus dem letzten Lockdown.
Das weltberühmte Café Florian:
Noch bleibt es unter der Woche geschlossen.
Vor der Pandemie waren die Straßen
voll mit Touristen aus der ganzen Welt.
20 Millionen Besucher im Jahr brachten
der Stadt Geld und veränderten sie.
Einige hoffen,
dass nach der Pandemie ein Neuanfang folgt.
Der Aktivist David Bozarro hat mit seiner
Gruppe Venessia.com diese Tafel installiert.
Er zeigt den Bevölkerungsschwund der Stadt.
50.965 ist die aktuelle Zahl der Menschen,
die heute in Venedig leben.
Das sind 30 Leute weniger
als in der Woche davor.
Der Massentourismus
treibt die Bewohner aus der Stadt.
Aber das Problem liegt tiefer.
Venedig selbst leidet darunter,
dass der Mangel an Touristen für viele
Menschen einen Mangel an Arbeit bedeutet.
Das erleben wir jetzt gerade.
Wissen Sie,
es ist eine merkwürdige Situation.
Wir wollen nicht zu viel Tourismus,
weil er den Ort ersticken würde.
Gleichzeitig können wir
ohne Tourismus nicht leben.
Dort, wo jeder auf die ein
oder andere Weise vom Tourismus lebt,
ist es schwierig, eine Balance zu finden.
Der Tourismusbeauftragte
der Stadt erzählt uns,
die Situation sei nicht einzigartig für Venedig,
wohl benötige Venedig aber
eine einzigartige Lösung.
In Venedig hat kein Ausverkauf stattgefunden.
Alle beliebten Touristenstädte
haben in den letzten Jahren erlebt,
dass klare Regeln fehlen,
um Teile der Stadt zu schützen.
Es wäre nötig,
bestimmte Gesetze einzuführen
für Städte wie Venedig und Florenz,
um für ein ausgewogenes Verhältnis
von Touristen und Bewohnern zu sorgen.
Als einen ersten Schritt
hat die Stadt damit begonnen,
die Besucherzahlen genauer zu verfolgen.
Im nächsten Jahr wird für Touristen
eine Eintrittsgebühr fällig.
Maurizio Carlotto hingegen vermisst,
was manche
die schlechte alte Zeit nennen würden.
Ich würde auch dahin zurückgehen,
wie es vor zwei Jahren war,
mit ein paar Leuten weniger vielleicht.
Aber es war kein Massaker,
wie sie immer sagen.
Es war nachhaltig.
Die Debatte darüber, wie die Zukunft
des Tourismus in der Stadt aussehen wird,
ist noch lange nicht zu Ende geführt.
Aber jetzt freut sich Venedig
erst mal wieder auf Besucher.